- WAIT A MINUTE.
COME ON!
- OW, OW!
[grunting]
OW!
- AH!
- GOT HIM. YES!
- OKAY. GUESS WHO
I VOTED FOR IN 2000.
BUSH.
O-OH.
MY FAVORITE BAND?
PUBIC ENEMY.
[chuckles]
- GOTTA TELL YOU, TEZ,
SOME SPREAD YOU GOT HERE.
- DUH.
- CAN I CROSS A LINE HERE
AND JUST ASK HOW
YOU CAN AFFORD TO LIVE
IN A PLACE LIKE THIS?
- IF YOU MUST KNOW,
COLLEEN GOT PROMOTED
TO PRINCIPAL
AT JOHN G. NEIHARDT ELEMENTARY.
- AHA!
- AND IT DON'T HURT THAT
ALICE GAVE ME A TWO-YEAR
PAY BUMP AT WORK.
- WHAT?
- MM-HMM. [chuckles]
WAYMOND, GET OUT THIS POOL
AND TAKE A SHOWER!
HOW MANY TIMES
I GOTTA TELL YOU?
[shivering]
- LISTEN, I GOTTA
TELL YOU SOMETHING.
- IT'S COLD, DERS!
- LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
- CAN WE GET SOME OF YOUR FOOD?
- GUYS, STOP. NO!
- LET ME GET A LITTLE BITE
OF YOUR SANDWICH!
- THERE WAS WHOLE SPREAD!
YOU SHOULD'VE GOTTEN SOME
WHILE IT WAS HOT.
- NO WAY. THEN WE'D HAVE TO
WAIT 30 MINUTES TO SWIM.
AND WE HAD TO DUNK
SOME FOOLS, MAN.
- I DUNKED SO MANY FOOLS!
- DID YOU? I'M SURE.
- WAYMOND ALMOST DROWNED!
- YEAH, THAT WAS COOL.
- COOL. ALL RIGHT, WELL, ANYWAY,
I GOTTA TELL YOU SOMETHING.
LISTEN, I GUESS TEZ
JUST GOT A RAISE.
ALL RIGHT?
NOW, ALICE IS OVER THERE.
SHE'S REAL DRUNK.
WE GO OVER THERE NOW,
MAYBE WE CAN GET A RAISE.
YOU FEEL ME?
- AW, I FEEL YOU SO MUCH.
CAN I JUST DIP MY FINGER
IN THE MAYONNAISE?
- LET ME JUST
GET YOUR PICKLE.
- TAKE THE PICKLE.
- YEAH, I GOT A PICKLE!
- I DON'T LIKE VEGETABLES, SO
THAT DOESN'T EVEN MATTER TO ME.
- UGH, THESE ARE THE NEON ONES.
I HATE NEON PICKLES.
- ALICE!
HEADING TO POUND TOWN, HUH?
- I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE
SUCH A PARTY BEAST.
YOU SHOULD COME, LIKE,
RAGE WITH US
AT OUR--NAH.
- YEP.
TWO YEARS OF SOBRIETY,
GENTLEMEN.
- GOOD FOR YOU!
- OH!
- TWO YEARS, GONE.
[laughs]
- OH, IT'S A BAD THING.
- YEAH.
- OH, YEAH.
UGH.
- I SAW THIS HOUSE
AND THIS AWESOME NEIGHBORHOOD,
AND I WAS LIKE...
PBBT! SCREW IT.
- DRINK THE PAIN AWAY.
GOOD CALL, GOOD CALL.
- ELBOW DROP
FROM THE TOP ROPE, BITCHES!
- ALICE, I BELIEVE
A WOMAN OF YOUR TALENTS
AND YOUR AMBITIONS
DESERVES EVERYTHING
IN YOUR WILDEST DREAMS.
- WHAT ARE
YOUR WILDEST DREAMS, ALICE?
- TEZ TOLD ME YOU GAVE HIM
A TWO-YEAR PAY BUMP,
SO I WAS THINKING MAYBE--
- FINE.
- WHOA.
- COOL, REALLY?
- WOW.
- YEP, YOU GOT IT.
- THAT WAS EASY.
- GIL, CAN I BUM
A SMOKE, BABE?
- SO WE'LL STOP BY
IN THE MORNING AT THE OFFICE
JUST TO IRON OUT THE DETAILS?
- YEAH,
WORKS FOR ME!
- ALL RIGHT.
SEE YOU THEN!
RAISES!
- [laughs] ALL RIGHT!
- WE GOT RAISES!
- YEAH!
- THAT WAS SO EASY.
WE JUST GOT RAISES.
LET'S GO SMOKE WEED
ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW.